بنيامين نتنياهو هو
رئيس الوزراء الأكثر خبرة في
تاريخ إسرائيل ، لكنه يواجه
معارك متعددة الأوجه غير مسبوقة على كل
توترات في الجبهات تقريبًا وأعمال عنف بين الإسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين عند أعلى مستوى لها منذ 20 عامًا يوم
الأحد ، حيث أحرقت الضفة الغربية المحتلة اثنين من
الأخوان الإسرائيليين بالرصاص قتلت نقطة بلانك
أثناء جلوسه في زحمة السير وما
يقول المسؤولون إنه هجوم إرهابي
ثم فيما اعتبر
هجمات انتقامية من قبل المستوطنين الإسرائيليين ، أطلق
رجل فلسطيني النار وقتل منازل
وسيارات أحرقت بعد ساعات فقط من
اجتماع مسؤولين إسرائيليين وفلسطينيين في
قمة في الأردن تهدف إلى تهدئة التوترات.
بيان مشترك يتعهد باتخاذ
خطوات لاستعادة الهدوء بحثًا عن سلام عادل ودائم
في الوقت نفسه ، في الوقت نفسه ،
يبدو أن شركاء نتنياهو في التحالف اليميني المتطرف يرفضون
القمة في الأردن مدعين أنه
لن يكون هناك تجميد في بناء السينما الذي
يعتبر غير قانوني بموجب
القانون الدولي ، الرسالة تخرج
كاتب سيرة نتنياهو  يقول Angel pfeffer إن الكثير من
الجدل الدائر حول نتنياهو
يرجع إلى هؤلاء الشركاء الحاكمين ،
وأعتقد أن هذا هو أقل ما كان نتنياهو
يسيطر عليه كرئيس للوزراء ،
فهو في الأساس لا يدير
حكومته التي يديرها
شركاء التحالف الذين لديهم
خلال ثمانية أسابيع متتالية ، خرج عشرات
الآلاف من الإسرائيليين
إلى الشوارع للاحتجاج على
الإصلاحات القضائية الهائلة التي يخطط لها نتنياهو ، ومن شأن
هذه التغييرات الأكثر شمولاً أن
تمنح البرلمان الإسرائيلي سلطة
إلغاء قرارات المحكمة العليا التي
يجادل بها العديد من النقاد.  إنه جزء من حيلة لمساعدة
نتنياهو على الخروج من
محاكمته الجارية بشأن الفساد ، وهو أمر ينفيه
المشاهد الدرامية في البرلمان مع
دفع التشريع خلال
مرحلته الأولى ، ولكنه أيضًا تحذيرات دراماتيكية من
قطاع التكنولوجيا الفائقة الإسرائيلي المربح وغير السياسي عادةً ، حيث
بدأت الأموال  ترك إسرائيل بفضل هذه
الإصلاحات التي أطلقنا عليها اسم دولة الشركات الناشئة ،
ونقول بشكل أساسي: هيا
لا تخاطر ، لقد صوت المستثمرون الأجانب
بأقدامهم ويواجه
نتنياهو
ضغوطًا دولية متزايدة من الحلفاء ،
لا سيما الولايات المتحدة التي
لم تنتقد التوسع الاستيطاني فقط
وبعض الإجراءات الإسرائيلية في
الضفة الغربية المحتلة ولكن أيضًا
توغل رئاسي نادر في
السياسة الإسرائيلية الداخلية حث الرئيس بايدن على
التوصل إلى توافق في الآراء بشأن الإصلاحات القضائية.  لقد
كانت القضية تتعلق
بإيران ولم تكن أبدًا تتعلق بالطريقة التي تتبعها
الحكومة الإسرائيلية للتشريع
على أجندة ديمقراطية وهذه هي
المرة الأولى التي نرى فيها
رئيسًا
يوبخ رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي علنًا تقريبًا
بشأن مثل هذه الأمور
في التقويم.  كانت حساسة للغاية في
فترة تجاوز شهر
رمضان في عيد الفصح والتي تهدد
بإشعال النار في القدس وكذلك
جبهة معركة أخرى لنتنياهو الناجي
النهائي لإسرائيل الآن.
CNN Jerusalem
الخارجية